your life sucks come hang out with us
for a weekend we're starting fraternity
we just put it out in uh yeah we just
put it out on on like craigspace
craigslist craigspace craigslist yeah
and it and uh and we got a lot of
replies and i say this respectfully but
a lot of very broken men and
how many people came showed up 20 25
yeah and we moved him into a house in
the hills and the hills of what of
hollywood in this huge house under a
waterfall
and we
me theo and brett created
i mean they gave us the we could do
whatever we wanted and so we're like
well we need to throw a party and
they're like how are we gonna get people
to come and we're like why don't we just
get prostitutes and porn stars
prostitute support stars but why is that
different than any other party in the
hollywood hills
it got so out of control so quickly and
like
nothing it was so under produced it was
like and i'm no disrespectful but a
murray but it was just such a wild west
so one of the things they did they had
scheduled like that we would go steal a
goat and so but that was scheduled
that's really one thing
we're going to get you guys this this
big tour bus and and it'll take you guys
out to the house and on the way there
you guys need a mascot so steal a good
it was our idea and they just arranged a
farm where we could take a goat well we
got drunk and we were like take a right
here so we took it right and then we're
like all right guys
we're getting a mascot we're stealing a
goat and we
broke into someone's farm for real and
stole a real goal goat wait you said it
was set up you thought
and then we put it on the bus and the
producer came and he's like all right so
you're gonna have them pull over like
two blocks that's where we're gonna find
the goat we're like the goat's on the
bus
and he was like
we're not there yet and we're like no we
got it and he's like no no that's not
our goat we're like we really just stole
a coat
oh [ __ ] just go just go let's go and
then we had to go like we had we had
already planned you know we'd pick it up
and then we'd take it we used some shots
for it and then they'd come get it we
had a goat we had a goat in a house in
the hills on a tennis court just wow
because there is no way to pick i mean
we got we got prostitutes and porn stars
to come party with us and like this is
like this is like an hour's into the
this is brian the first day the first
moments and this guy comes up and he's
like i just cheated on my fiancee i just
what i just cheated on my fiancee and
we're like i don't know what to tell you
man he's like i think i'm ruining my
life
i mean it was like so crazy like one guy
had ptsd had been back from iraq and he
was just like you could tell he was
really dealing with it and
i mean it was just such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show that we like oh it was so funny
where is the tape i tried to buy it from
bunda murray and they wouldn't i
remember the sound guy came up to me and
he goes he was hey man i'm pretty sure
your buddy's getting his dick sucked in
the bathroom and i'm like what he goes
here gives me the headsets and i'm just
hearing
oh my god i'm like we can't use any of
this like we were just thinking it was
the most aggressive
hilarious
funniest no one will ever see it show
[Music]